CLAUDIO: Hi everyone, and
welcome back to the Google
Drive SDK question time.
My name is Claudio
and this is Ali.
ALI: Hi everyone.
CLAUDIO: We are two engineers in
the Google Drive developer
relations team.
Today we're going to show you
a tool we have developed
called the OAuth
2.0 Playground.
We think this tool will make
it easy for developers and
users in general to
test the API.
So it can be used for many APIs
but today we're going to
use it for the Drive API.
Ali, can you tell us a bit
more about the OAuth
Playground?
ALI: So we use OAuth 2.0 as
our best authorization
mechanism for using
all our APIs.
It's not only just us, it's
becoming an industry standard
way of authorization.
Now we developed this tool
called the OAuth 2.0
Playground that allows you to
debug and test and experiment
with the OAuth flow.
If you've ever used OAuth, you
know it's not entirely simple.
It's quite straightforward,
but there are a few steps.
And what this tool does is it
allows you to go through the
steps, it shows you how they
work, it shows you the full
debugging output, and then it
allows you to make requests
with APIs using the
authorization credentials that
you've got.
CLAUDIO: Let's see
how we can use it
with a set of scenarios.
So I think we can start from
the Google Drive UI.
And the OAuth 2.0 Playground is
integrated with the UI, so
we can start from there and see
how we can reach to the
application.
ALI: OK.
So this is the Google Drive
user interface.
I'm sure you're all
familiar with it.
But one thing we've allowed with
the OAuth Playground is
we allow you to open files from
the drive user interface
in the OAuth Playground.
OK.
So here's a list of files.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to right-click on this.
Because I've got the OAuth 2.0
Playground installed and a few
other drive apps, I just click
Open with the OAuth 2.0
Playground.
And what happens is I get an
authorization request and it
goes through the first
step of OAuth.
So you can see here, if you're
familiar with OAuth 2.0, you
know that once authorization
has happened, a redirect
occurs to the server with
the code and the
information I need.
The code is here in this box and
this allows me to perform
the next step of the OAuth 2.0
dance, which is to exchange
the code for a token.
And if you see, I've exchanged
the code here, just go back
there, and I've got
this access token.
Quickly copy that down, because
you'll be able to use
it to access my data.
It's OK, it's just a test
account so there's nothing
really you can do in there.
Once you've done that, you can
then make API requests.
Now, because I opened this file
directly in the OAuth
Playground, it's already
preloaded a request for me.
And so what do I do?
I make that API request
and I get a response.
Let's just look at
that quickly.
So what was the request
we made?
Well, it was a Get here to that
URL using the code that--
the access token that we just
obtained, which is there.
And we get a response.
It's a 200.
Fantastic.
The usual kind of headers,
content length.
And then the JSON response.
And if you've seen any of our
documentation or if you used
our APIs, you know this
is fairly standard.
There are few fields,
interesting ones.
Download URL we'll have
a look at later.
The title, which is test image,
which you can see
corresponds to the title in
the drive user interface.
And the MIME type of the file,
which is an image.png.
Makes sense.
We have some labels here that
refer to Boolean attributes on
the file itself, whether it's
starred, whether it's hidden,
whether it's trashed.
That kind of thing.
So this allows you immediately
to get into a situation where
you are debugging driver API
calls directly from the drive
user interface.
CLAUDIO: That's perfect and that
works perfectly and it's
super easy when you start
from the drive UI.
So you just right-click on a
file and you open it from the
OAuth Playground.
But what if you want to start
directly from the OAuth
Playground?
ALI: OK.
So this big X here resets
all the settings.
That's great.
So I've reset all of that.
Now, when you do OAuth 2.0--
and this was preselected for us
when we came from the drive
user interface, but
you have to pick a
scope or multiple scopes.
And you see all our APIs are
listed here, but the one we're
interested in is the
Google Drive scope.
We click Authorize and, of
course, we're going to get
through to the OAuth
authorization page.
This is what a user would see to
say, do you give access to
this application or not?
And you can see the application
here is the OAuth
Playground.
So we allow access and we get
redirected back here with the
code which we exchange
as before.
CLAUDIO: So starting from here,
it's exactly the same
flow as before.
ALI: Exactly.
It's slightly different.
You might have noticed that
here, we have a refresh token,
and previously we didn't
have a refresh token.
This just means that we can have
offline access, ie, when
our access token expires, we can
refresh it and get a new
access token.
So that's the only difference,
but apart from that, it's
exactly the same.
Now, what we can do here is we
can enter our custom request.
That was preselected
for us before.
But what we find is this really
useful button called
Find Available Request URIs.
And that gives an ordered list
of all the endpoints for this
API with the various parameters
that you need.
So what was the first thing
you wanted to do, Claudio?
CLAUDIO: I would say that the
first thing is to list all the
files the OAuth Playground
is allowed to open.
So we look for a list files
method and that
should be it, right?
ALI: Yeah.
That's just there.
So you can click on the URI and
it preloads it in there.
That's all we're doing.
And it will show you that you
just need to make a Get to
this request, send the request,
and here's our response.
Do you want talk about
this a bit, Claudio?
CLAUDIO: Sure.
So the response is
now field feed
containing a number of entries.
For each entry, as the one you
showed before, there is a set
of attributes we set.
Each of them has a number
of links to download the
document, export a document in
different formats, and another
set of metadata, like the
title, the MIME type.
This case the one we're looking
at right now is a text
file, a plain text file.
And the same levels as before.
So if this item has being
starred, if it's in trash,
something else like
the extension--
a very useful MD5 checksum,
which is a checksum for the
content of the file.
So you can use that field to
know if the content has
changed and many other details,
including the name of
the owner, the size of this file
on your storage, who is
the user that last modified
it, and what are your
permissions on this file?
ALI: So this is interesting
because as you might may know
in Google Drive, you have
two kinds of files.
One are binary files that we
store the content, and the
other type are Google
Docs files.
Now, some of these attributes
are only available for binary
files, for example, the original
file name, the amount
of quota the file is using.
Google Docs files and Google
Docs spreadsheets,
presentations, drawings--
all of these occupy zero
of your quota.
That's just worth saying.
So you get two slightly
different types, and these are
only present-- and, of course,
the MD5 checksum is only
present on these kind
of files as well.
CLAUDIO: Can we download
a file from here?
ALI: So it's a text file.
So conveniently with the OAuth
Playground, you can't download
binary files, unfortunately.
That's a feature that we
should probably add.
But you can download text files
because it's just text.
So one thing we've got in here
is the download URL.
So you can just click on this
download URL and you see it's
preloaded now in the
Request URI.
And if I click on Send the
Request, before I do it, it
will make an authorized Get
request to this, which it
needs to be authorized.
Of course, we don't want to
share this file with just
anyone, even if they know
what the link is.
So we make that request
and fingers
crossed, it should work.
I think it's going to.
You get a 200 with some
interesting information in the
headers, actually.
For example, the content
disposition which allows your
application to create the
correctly named file, in this
case hello.txt.
And we go down to the bottom and
we see the content of the
file, Hello Drive SDK users.
CLAUDIO: Well, how
cheesy it that?
ALI: Well, I didn't even
prepare it for this.
I'm joking.
I did prepare it for this.
CLAUDIO: I believed you.
ALI: So that's how you
use the Download URL
and you can do that.
I can't show you with any
binary files because,
obviously, binary data would
not be rendered properly in
this browser.
So that's why we're using
a text file here.
CLAUDIO: What about exporting
documents
in different formats?
We're not going to do it now,
but how can you do that?
ALI: OK.
So just to show you that,
let's just pick a file.
Now for exporting, we're talking
about Google Docs
types really, aren't we?
So which one would you like?
One of these Google Docs
files, I guess.
Probably presentation?
CLAUDIO: It's probably
presentation.
ALI: Let's use that one.
So if I just open that with--
this saves me listing a
file, finding the ID,
performing a Get on it.
It just saves all of
that information.
So let's get the file and we
see here in the file for
Google Docs types, we will
have a export link.
CLAUDIO: We sent a request
to Version 1 of the API.
ALI: Rather than Version
2 of the API.
I can just about see that.
Let's see.
Will that work?
OK.
So now we've got that and we see
among all these links, we
will have a link--
a set of links called
the export links.
Now, these are great because
although you could probably
try and construct that URL
manually, we strongly advise
against you doing that.
But for each type you
can export, in
this case, txt, pdf,--
CLAUDIO: OpenOffice--
ALI: OpenOffice presentations.
It offers you a different
download URL that you can use.
CLAUDIO: Well actually,
that is not OpenOffice
presentation.
I lied.
That is pptx.
So it's a new format for
Microsoft PowerPoint
presentation.
ALI: Interesting.
CLAUDIO: So you just take
that link, download the
file from that link.
And then you get the file
in exported format.
ALI: Exactly.
And we can't show you
because, of course,
they are binary formats.
CLAUDIO: And how can you know
what the available export
formats are?
ALI: OK.
So this really depends on the
type of file, but we do list
this information in what we
call-- and let's start again.
We call the About feed.
OK.
While I'm doing this, do you
just want to explain a bit
about the About feed.
CLAUDIO: So in the Drive
API, we have many feeds
that you can get.
The one we have used so far is
the File Scope, which is the
feed you have to use to list all
your files, to search for
files, to download
files, and so on.
But there are others, including
the Permissions
feeds, which returns permissions
for a file or a
folder, or the Changes feed,
which lists old changes that
happen to your document list.
But there is also another feed
called the About feed.
The About feed includes--
it's a read-only feed that
includes a set of metadata.
So you can get the list of
available export formats for
all of the source documents we
know, a list of reports from
us for all the documents we
can import, and other
information we're going
to show you
when we get that feed.
ALI: So as you can see, I've
just clicked on this link
here, About.
And the URL is easy.
It's just a Get to
our API with the
version and then About.
And I click Get.
And of course, I'm going to get
a 200 response back, and
with loads of information.
So just to shoot quickly to what
Claudio was talking about
with the export formats, there
we see a list of export
formats, each one specifying
the source, so you can see
here that a drawing will export
to an svg, a jpg, a
png, or a pdf.
CLAUDIO: That's the native
Google Docs drawing, right?
ALI: Exactly right.
And then, likewise, a native
Google document that can
export to OpenOffice, Word, HTML
obviously, a rich text, a
plain text, or a PDF.
So this is fairly predictable,
but it's really worth looking
at this feed so you can know
what kind of files are going
to be able to be exported from
the native documents.
Pretty useful, I think, so
you can display the right
thing to the user.
CLAUDIO: What other
information do we
get from this feed?
One question we often get is,
how do I know how much disk
space I have on Google Drive,
and how much of that disk
space is available?
ALI: So apart from metadata
about things the user can do,
there's also metadata
about the account.
It's kind of a miscellaneous
feed with the
information that you need.
And there are some quota
fields, as well.
So the first one here
is quotaBytesTotal.
That's how much total
quota the user has.
In this case, it's Claudio.
How much of the quota is being
used, which is a small amount.
And how much is used in trash?
And this helps you to, perhaps,
display to the user
that they're running
out of quota.
Or if the user in your
application wants to upload a
huge file, well, you can predict
that there's not
enough quota to upload
that file.
So you can say, no,
I'm not going to
perform this operation.
Delete some files or buy
some more quota.
CLAUDIO: And the value for the
quota used by files in trash
can be useful for you to know
anytime how much disk space
you can recover without deleting
any important file.
So you know that all of those
files were deleted by the
users, so if you empty the
trash, you just recovered some
space and only lose
non-important things.
ALI: So let's go through some
of these other ones because
they are kind of interesting
for highlighting
features of the API.
So here I've got what
is a root folder ID.
Can you tell us a bit about the
root folder and what the
root folder ID would be?
CLAUDIO: Oh, yes.
So in Drive, files
can be organized
in different folders.
And a single file can have
multiple parents, which we
call folders.
And a folder, of course, could
have multiple children.
And so when you try to draw the
structure of all files in
Google Drive, this structure
would look like a tree.
And, of course, as all trees,
at the top of it there would
be a root folder that we want
to be always available for
developers.
So we have--
the root folder is a folder
like any other folder.
So it has an ID.
It is actually a file like
all other folders.
But at any time if you want to
know how to get the content of
the root folder, if you want
to get some specific
information about the root
folder, you can access that by
using this ID.
We also added some convenience
methods to do that.
And actually, we added an alias
for the root folders.
If you don't want to know or
if you don't want to check
what the ID for the root folder
is, you can always
refer to it using the string
root, which is
quite easy to remember.
ALI: So you have a choice
there which
one you want to use.
So thanks for explaining that.
And I think this will
conveniently get us on to the
next thing we want
to talk about.
What's the largest change ID?
CLAUDIO: So we have this other
feed that I briefly mentioned
earlier, which is called
the changes feed.
With the changes feed--
what the changes feed contains
is a list of entries.
And each entry represents
some changes to the
documents list you have.
So let's say you want to
synchronize your local files
with the files in
Google Drive.
Instead of having to download
all your files and check each
of them with your local copy,
you can simply synchronize
once by downloading all the
files, sorting the change ID
corresponding to that moment
in time when you downloaded
all the files, and then only
check the Changes feed, which
will tell you something like
on the change ID x, a
new file was added.
On change x plus 1, this file
has been deleted or this file
has changed its metadata
or its content.
ALI: Shall we look?
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
Let's have a look at what the
Changes feed looks like.
ALI: So back again we'll look
at the available feeds.
You don't ever need to remember
these URIs, of course.
You just need to know where
to find it in--
CLAUDIO: They're also pretty
easy to remember in case you
want to, because they all have
the same RESTful structure.
So they all start with
www.googleapis.com slash the
name of the API, which is drive,
slash the version which
is v2 since Google I/O, and
then slash the name of the
feed, in this case is
going to be change.
ALI: With any additional query
parameters or path parameters,
but this feed doesn't
have any.
So, again, the Change
feed is read-only.
So I've done a Get there.
And this time I get a list
of drive changes, a
drive change list.
And you can see them here.
So as Claudio was saying,
each one--
each change has an ID.
CLAUDIO: We should say
it's increasing.
It's an integer, it's a
monotonic increasing integer.
So you can always trust that the
new ones will be greater
than the previous ones.
ALI: It's actually stored as
a string, but there we go.
And then the file that the
change referred to.
So that's by the file ID.
Now, here is where we have a
choice of how we behave, how
we were return with
this field.
So a file could be deleted.
Now, if it's being deleted,
obviously we don't return the
file data, because that data
doesn't exist anymore.
So the change itself describes
at the top level whether it
refers to a delete operation
or a modify operation.
And if it hasn't been deleted,
ie deleted is set to false, we
also have the entire file
data in the feed here.
CLAUDIO: By the entire
file they mean all
the metadata, right?
We don't return the content.
ALI: Of course.
So the content, no.
Just the file metadata
is contained in here.
CLAUDIO: This is consistent with
what we always do when
retrieving the list of files.
We never return the content
together with the metadata.
We return the link to the
content and then you have to
download it.
Because remember, the metadata
is very small, so you can
always get it, but the content
can be pretty big.
A file in Google Drive can be
up to 10 gigabytes, so we
don't want to return 100
gigabytes every time you want
to know the list of
files you have.
ALI: Exactly.
So Claudio, tell me why there's
only one file in this
list of changes.
CLAUDIO: Because we only
changed one file.
ALI: We only changed one file.
OK.
That's it.
If we look at the actual file
itself, it was a Google Docs
letter to the employees.
CLAUDIO: Oh yeah.
ALI: Good one.
So here you can see the ID
Claudio was talking about, and
that refers also to the largest
change ID that we've--
CLAUDIO: Let's say you
synchronize your local status
with this change, which is
number 1620, I think,
if I can read it.
So next time, we can
go to the next--
starting from the largest
change ID, which
is 2533, plus 1.
ALI: Plus 1.
Do you remember what the
query parametere is?
CLAUDIO: Nope.
ALI: No, neither do I.
CLAUDIO: It's
[? not in any of ?] the
documentation.
Whenever you request the changes
feed, you can say,
don't give me all of it, just
give me everything starting
from ID number.
And so next time, you want to
start from an ID number that
is greater than that.
OK, cool.
I think that's perfect.
I think there's only one
question left, which is, how
do we get this?
ALI: How do we get it?
CLAUDIO: Yeah.
ALI: Well, you just go to the
website, code.google.com/
oauthplayground, and you
can just start using it
immediately.
If you have Google Drive--
if you use Google Drive, then
you can also go to the Chrome
Web Store and install the
OAuth 2.0 Google Drive
application that is responsible
for this
functionality where you can
open a file directly.
OK.
So that's in--
well, we'll add the URL
somewhere so you can look at
it when you're looking
at this.
CLAUDIO: Perfect.
Thank you very much, Ali.
ALI: OK.
Thank you, Claudio.
And thanks for watching.
Take care.